what's up everybody welcome back to
GameSpot cross kind of funny I'm Greg
that's Colin and this is Mike biffle's
number one tester shoe hey you thank you
shoe for making time for us our annual
sit down conversation with you it's good
to have you what you have a much better
view this year all the weeks on the
second floor it's amazing in a political
fierce game I want to go play that's why
this is really a serious game you can
play yeah we made it very short
five-minute session but three and three
in the battle is so fun you know you
want to play a game and being on the
game yeah that's the game I want to go
see ya all right
the man with the first question the
tradition dictates that we first ask
about Sony Bend so of course where Sony
been why hiding Eric Jensen
whoa we have we have other projects we
excited to announce horizon well
actually you know help Harmon announce
horizon and it's a huge title you know
the team started development of horizon
right after the Killzone 3 you know so
team after Killzone 3 team spread into
Killzone Shadowfall team and horizon
team and so it's over like four years
that team has been making it's a huge
you know endeavor after the shadow for
lots of people join the horizon so
similarly the North dog structure kind
of a fourth yeah and the Media Molecule
after so many years since
LittleBigPlanet - yeah because little
big final three was done by in awesome
oh yeah so the they spent another like
four years
so these studios have been working on
new project new concept new IP on ps4
for a long time so you know each one
need to so the been guys in a good news
is I'm super excited about Ben
Studios game and just few weeks ago I
had a chance to play
playin Artie you're saying they're gonna
announce it it'll come out right away
say never say never
I'll say never say never but yeah it's
it's really really looking good and
playing good but I cannot say what is of
course of course yeah of course not
so look we should start with horizon
because I think that was the game that
really that really kind of blew us away
don't you I mean it blew us away I I I
mean I would say start like Sony start
with Last Guardian but if you want to
sell chronological view for both of you
to choosing horizon as well V yeah I
watched stream right hi Jennifer me
think I was busy right taking interviews
but is very funny you know what games
are you picking thank you yeah on the
way with the tearaway boys and girls
scared them now ratchets walking around
the guy from galaxy Nick will get to
them eventually I think's gonna dance up
on everybody that's not nothing can stop
next dance
oh there's Nicky's dance around right
now no one no one could see you dance
for Shuhei Yoshida he likes that
dance dance dance like yesterday I took
interview by again yes who interviewed
me hundred gold you know saying
something oh okay sure so you have
announced and you came from a gala and
media mogul but you have some other
studios who haven't and I'm like are you
a premium or use like a bad penny we
can't get rid of them we have we have so
many questions for you I wish you but
we're gonna cut to commercial real quick
then come back and keep dancing for you
probably Nick dance this out dance out
one more time we're going to commercial
break real quick get up here and dance
dance Russia raise some more your you
can see it kinda funny
all right as I live and breathe
we're backless Shuhei Yoshida president
of Sony worldwide studios the probably
most beloved man in video games there's
no doubt about it you weren't you are
the you are the ultimate now everyone
knows you everyone loves you and I talk
to add a voice about you because he was
on earlier we were talking about it and
I brought up the fact that some
developer friends of ours who will
remain nameless had said like it's so
awesome that you guys and she would have
this relationship and he's great but he
he could be he can be really tough in
the business boardroom like you guys
think he's all fun and games and he
likes Nick Danson but there's times when
he's like no I won't give you a matter
of this side or the other and then Adam
said that's true that happens every so
often but your your kids your kids turns
you around made you a softer overall yes
I'm Suzy
you know very well yeah so I was a bit
more difficult manager before I had
children yeah but now I'm super easy all
right so last Guardian yes what did that
feel like when the lights came back up
in you were on stage and everybody was
going nuts yeah so I was waiting in the
back room with Edison and watching you
know Sean leading starts and it's filled
Holly oh you know I was thinking back
about you know many things and I
couldn't be we have come to this point
but so the presentation for me was the
easiest thing for me to do any
presentation because I just had to be
myself yeah I just say thank you and say
I'm so happy I mean the questions so
much just comments I think it looks
awesome and I'm excited that you know
they showed I show the portion that you
showed and then the portion that led up
to that portion basically the one thing
I noticed they were talking about it
Tomiko not a thing anymore I mean it it
seems like the Tamiko get disbanded like
that internal team at Japan studio
because it seems like Japan studio is
helping to finish it along with the team
that I had never heard of before so it
depends on how you define Kimiko okay
well many members of Kimiko
original eco team it was still small
team like 20 plus people moved on to
shadow of the course
and added more people the shuttle was
larger like a 40 people also and after
that the widow Sam became independent
but working with the Queen him it's a
just a rearrangement of vacations okay
because now whether Sam has established
his reputation and he wants more freedom
in to spend how he spend his time and he
might work on some other concept so also
he chose to become independent but you
know still welcome in the last galleon
and it's a main project that he is
working on and the other member actually
the new new studio gen design genocide
was established the president of
organisation used to be the lead
programmer of eco unshod of the process
and some inner core member was the
shadow team and horizon-- became
independent and not to do you know
creative stuff too but but the main
development team is still in Japan
studios okay yeah because the project
went on so many technical you know
changes you know so the after we decided
we decided to move the product to ps4 in
2012 but the because ps3 was so code was
so optimized 2sp used on ps3 a lots of
code had to be thrown away you know
under the build from the ground up so
during that time in a way design and the
core creative in a while continuing to
work on creatives but without a game up
and running you know they had to a long
time of way so that the set of very good
that they had a little bit of their own
space and they could have worked on some
other concept but the main development
has
East Japan studio and Gen design in
creating a lot of creative side you know
contribution to the product and the
widow Sam is directing the overall
creative was also where the Sun was not
fired okay I watched you stream that's
totally bogus yeah so
no cuz that well that was shampoo a
manufactured by me that wasn't that was
the thing that was that was circulating
sometime ago about your way to Sun so in
terms of him leaving the studio a while
ago there was there were some rumors out
there that we were we reported on back
way back in the day that there was some
bad blood or whatever so we were just
kind of wondering what the situation was
with that so I I'm I would super
interested in that so there was never a
time with the difficulty of developing
this game where you guys didn't want to
maybe do it anymore you always do you
wanted a at the Last Guardian out well
yeah I believed in the concept and we
the son of course wanted to project to
be realized and the core members you
know always wanted the game to be
realized but what made us continue to
welcomes was the encouragement by lots
of people and journalists asked me and
asked us every time every Julia yeah
without that because we knew that lots
of people interviewed by the you know
project and the waiting for the game to
alive I felt it's a my responsibility to
you know get this game you know
completed and it was tough position to
move from ps3 to ps4 because the game
was running on ps3
but not at the performance that are
needed and you know why incremental in
Japan yeah he saw the game running but
at that point in a game of not running
at the framerate and some features are
missing so the we knew that the weather
will continue to make the game on ps3
with like a compromised vision right or
moved to ps4 and we knew it will take
lot more time but because of the all the
encouragement from people you know we
were able to you know continue the
product so I am so happy that we are the
project is in a really good state and
some people like journalists in a
point-blank asked me that you know we
don't believe the game will come out in
2016 and I'm like okay we have to prove
that's my question is that you know you
support us on patreon you watch the
content you listen to shows when Colin
was predicting it that it was going to
be a now City three-and-out this fall
was that ever something you were toying
around with have an idea where he wanted
this to happen like that but then it
just became 2016 well I I thought that
was a great idea but when I sold it but
I never you know it never occurred to me
because we we moved the project to ps4
so we could have said that now project
with ps4 but I didn't want to do it
until the time that we are confident
about our in a window and we can show
the game running on ps4 the video we
showed is actually the actual game you
know we are showing with a sign showing
off the actual code of the exact same
game you know that level that runs at
the same exact like a speed but so we my
thing was you know when we announced
last Guardian we have to have the game
you know totally learning on ps4 at the
performance and we are confident about
the this window that we're gonna
announce so that's you know in our mind
right you know we have the tech down and
we have the innovation and design then
lots of levels are already being made
and so we have a really good good you
know confidence about the 2016 so that
when they come yeah let's do it
excellent and just perfume out there no
I don't know I I did see the game behind
closed doors and you waited did play the
game for us and it was a real demo he
went to get the tail a direct like
grabbed at the yeah he's sail whatever
it missed and actually I died during the
demo so I thought that was actually cool
so it wasn't it's not automatically
happening as it might steal the page
from Naughty Dog's book like see hey
it's a real game we're running in here
so we want to talk about next version
Verizon we're gonna go how rise in the
cost yeah oh yeah like how that game was
long rumored and had leaked a while ago
in various different ways but you guys
had never spoken about it yet guerrilla
has been working on this game since
Killzone 3 sets 2011 that must been so
exciting because gorilla has really been
known as the Killzone studio for a
decade and now they're doing something
different so can you tell us all about
that yeah so the core team creatives of
gorillas have worked on you know chill
zone for a longest time and those people
like Mattias and really wanted to
something new right and so there are
lots of people who joined gorilla after
kids on world least you know wanted to
make you zone so it was a good kind of
setup to okay you know Mattias and the
core team work on new concept while the
other people including under Stephen to
work on Killzone Shadowfall and because
the concept that you know sort of
Mattias and the team came up with many
different concept and some of them were
really interesting but we narrowed down
you know finally to horizon
it's a it's ambitious title it's an
open-world action RPG and the guys had
never done open-world game or never done
action opposite yeah so hitting all
different new horizon as talked about
but you know the team really really
wanted so to do so we felt the technical
side you know gorilla has really really
you know strong technical foundation and
it's a second ps4 project even though
the team were separate the engines are
like you know continued on the you know
children share of all was the
fascination ps4 engine by a leader and
the horizon is their second gen in a
generation engine on ps4 so it it can do
amazing you know Vista and the hundred
lots of objects things but the gameplay
because it's totally new for gorilla so
the team what Tim did was really focused
on getting the gameplay up and running
very early in the process so game has
been credible over a year now and the
name in free testing and I have chance
to many you know times to play the game
and the leash and prey test our play in
version i have having a really really
you know fun you know there are many
different like robot have different a
and different set of you know
combinations or different types of
enemies and it's an RPG you can acquire
different weapons and I used you know
different kind of like arrows that has
additional Olivia so each setup creates
the inner initiation that you have to
come up with right you know tactics on
strategy to tackle and it feels really
really well and because it's an RPG and
the bust
you know amount of gameplay in it we
really wanted to make the gameplay you
know a minute-to-minute thing or
moment-to-moment feel to be right and
what excites me most is the team's focus
on that on the side of the game even
though what we thought was like a
beautiful like scenery you better charge
the first parties for a while now yeah
important is it to you that they stretch
their legs like this that they don't
they could have just kept making
Killzone it's a proven franchise people
love it but you want them to go do
something different I imagine right yeah
so the you know when teams has a
successful project typically they have
achieved like 60 to 80 percent of things
you know they set out you know they
envisioned to do with the first project
and also once in Arsenal's of was one
project is finished
you know team has already have we could
have done that we wanted to do this so
there are already ideas and lots of you
know energy and when the people lots of
people like that fast titles it's very
natural for the team to move on to the
second project right and from business
standpoint it's a safest way to run the
business because we know the you know
there are lots of funds already and the
core gameplay is already done so they
are very this small risk of doing a
sequel but when does you know project
continue to the second to the third
title to the fourth title yeah there are
you know fewer number of things that
we envision that happened you know tried
already and doing the same project again
and again you know now the length of the
project is longer two years three years
you know you might be working on the
same game for ten years right so that's
really you know risky situation for the
studio to be in so also from studio
management standpoint it's really
important for management like Harmon to
be able to assign people in different
types of game because always this you
know fatigue can happen and from overall
studio management portfolio management
starting point for me you know we like
to have a good balance of sequels of our
successful titles like Uncharted and you
know new risky concept like horizon or
dreams and you know I we always try to
have a good balance of both of them I
mean you brought up three media
molecules been quiet as you said they
made tearaway it's kind of a you know
small team within
Media Molecule made that game but
they've been working on this game for a
while and one of the funny things we
realized is that we kind of saw this
game at the ps4 reveal but no one had an
in 2013 but no one had really known what
we were looking at well I saw it at the
press conference and I don't know what
is this mini molecule that they're weird
I mean that's what that's what that's
that's in their DNA
they do strange things is this a game
that's gonna be very hard to message
because we're still not even sure what
it is yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's a huge
project it's like an exchange creation
platform by Media Molecule so you can
take you can slice and dice that project
in many different angles it's a huge
project in terms of what it can do as a
potential so we decided that in order
for us for people to understand what it
is it's gonna take some time to
digesting we cannot slow everything at
the same time so we strategize to use
the c32
pekes some interest into people you know
show some pretty graphics and show some
creation like a real-time creation and
the flexibility to animate or you know
up music and get people to think about
what it is you know we want to know more
and a Paris game show we're gonna show a
lot more the the whole scope of the
project interesting so it seems like it
sounds almost like a logical evolution
of something a little bit planner which
is also a created a creation tool yeah
it's much more flexible you know it's a
big planet you basically pretty much you
made a new level of you know action game
yeah but with dreams you don't have to
make a game you can make a game of any
kind but you don't have to make a game
if you are a painter if you can just
create you know future painterly looking
drawings or you can just animate the
character or you can take from other
people's creations when you show the
puppeteering
yes roller the thing is the basic
concept is making creations more
intuitive and put in the hands of not
persons who are trying to use the
complex 3d packages but make the
artistic person to create in art as if
they are doing it in real life
yeah so the weekends we are envisioning
like artists or musicians will
contribute something that they are
really good at and share it with lots of
people it's a you know community about
creators and anyone can take anyone's
creations and mashup and create even you
know grand large project including you
know games that's more semiquaver yes
you should present that game I've been
saying for years you should be out of
that stage more
what should happen that so now what I
want to jump to is in number okay two
minutes in 20 seconds that was the
entirety of your talk of Morpheus oh I
was blown away sure I fell over I
grabbed my heart I thought this is gonna
be the e3 where we talked a lot about
Morpheus and you guys made the case for
why it needs to be in everybody's home
what's happening oh because we did it
because when we spend more time than two
minutes and 20 seconds
other than core gamers games you hate
the other way you committed you showed
more games which is great but what's
happening with more fees when is
Morpheus this big Morpheus is project
it's going very very well and we have
you know 20 games that we've done that's
playable at this gen 3 and we have to
turn down more submissions from both
parties on our own fault party titles to
kind of in a prioritize to show at this
year's e3 so the hardware is on schedule
a lot of games are being created and
some games you know that we are showing
will hit in a lunch date that we haven't
decided yet so it's really going very
well and you saw in the conference that
we set up like pretty wide view screen
so you felt little bit like using you
know but a reality headset that you see
the wide view of the game but when you
are watching on the stream it's much
more limited on the small screen of the
smart home PC and so it's almost
impossible to communicate how it is like
to to play you know games in Morpheus so
we decided that the you know we need to
get people to experience you know on the
show floor and let them talk about their
experience and so we just announced that
there are these games you know available
to try on the sofa and
and let please try it because there are
lots of you know people in the audience
who be very good at the fornicating
right like we always talked about with
VR like using it is believing in it once
you put it on you get that thing you
then you understand I became a believer
when I used it eyes and I didn't you
know oculus first or Valkyrie just blew
me away and I do agree that it's gonna
be what it must be difficult for you
because it is one of those things that
you can't show someone they have to see
it for themselves so how are you gonna
overcome that challenge with Morpheus
yeah so including myself you know we all
of us involved in project Morpheus
project and developers who are making
games on via had one moment that like a
creek experiencing something now I
believe in it so because we know that's
necessary you cannot really think about
you know what it is like using booyah
you really have to experience it and the
second best thing is to watch people
doing the experience in a people totally
like ally acting like because when you
are wearing he said you forget their
people zahrain you right so you behave
really you know you'd react really
naturally yeah so that's a second best
thing so that's what we are focused on
at the e3 this time and games like weeks
that that's a core gamers game that's
that's a game we really wanted to show
and get people to experience and cause
you know even showing you know great
experience in like London highest or the
the deep you know it if anyone can enjoy
being a part of the story or situation
but you know because we are targeting
the gamers first you know with project
Mac well Morpheus we need to convince
people that you know with Morpheus you
can pray these Morpheus with with games
like leagues you can use Morpheus for
hours you know because you want to one
I'm surprised of meeting a lot of kind
of funny fans here at e3 and one of the
questions they keep asking me is
surprised me although I'm curious to is
what Sony Santa Monica up to a lot of
people were surprised at Santa Monica
hasn't known in a while and that's a
question that I'm getting pretty
consistently can you talk about anything
that Santa Monica is doing I know that
they they obviously are producing a lot
of games there as well so M Barse is
working Overton I saw dead Mars yeah
wonderful woman yeah but what
everybody's gone to the left such a
beautiful game and the music is amazing
and the storytelling you know judging
from the last game it's gonna be really
really good you know so for mature the
audience it's gonna be a treat so that's
coming up next month but what about
their internal I Triple A team yeah
what's going on with Tex there was a lot
of restructuring and a lot of movement
the last computer new studio for that
team it's an amazing studio I don't know
if you have this really nice it's a
beautiful place it's a high ceiling and
everybody can see you know each other
it's a great collaborative space that
the studio has created and Shannon stood
this fear is you know she's a studio
director now she's managing the entire
studio she used to be a producer go to
one and go to write and she has her own
soul searching for a few years and but
came back to actually she set up here on
developer to develop the playstation
allstars and after that project I needed
Alan Baker to move to Japan studio to
really turn on the studio and Japan
Studios producing now really great
product that I'm really excited about so
we needed someone to take over Alan's
shoes and channel is doing fantastic job
managing the studio a question I got on
Twitter today yeah I thought was I got a
question on Twitter today that I thought
was very astute and it was interesting
one you had told you were saying in
interviews that the first parties aren't
working on Vita games anymore really
I like Triple A Yankees them laughing oh
right sorry
right exactly
at when I was at Tokyo Game Show a
couple years ago you guys kind of
quietly revealed gravity rush - is it
sick like and you should I was just on
the screen and people were just looking
at and then you didn't really talked
about it again I think we said new
gravity or grabbed my gravity project
something yeah yeah everyone assumed
that that was maybe a sequel but I'm
curious is is that a ps4 game coming out
of Japan studio because we haven't heard
anything about that game since since
Tokyo in 2013 that's that's another
project we are waiting for the bear the
right time yeah I mean praying the game
for sometimes for Assassin's Creed 2 is
so much better that's where you suck
my question is shoe for you as a project
I'm really excited about play is a new
project by sucker-punch shoe is the
ultimate trol we never talked about his
Twitter of the other day when all the
members were going to your retweeting
rumors of how the kills okay you
retweeted the BR Killzone rumor but it
was it was Riggs it wasn't everyone so
everyone thought horizon was gonna be
was gonna be the VR game but it was
guerrilla Cambridge his game that was
rigged so it was making us all go crazy
on us he drops blood in the water and
all the piranhas go around testing more
and it's just a matter of few hours yeah
so I guess my question is for you Shu
and what we just talked about cuz you're
like oh if we talk about things in our
core games we get mad and [ __ ] about it
has the this is your first III after
PlayStation experience does knowing that
you have that outlet now change what you
feel like you have to talk about at e3
can you not can you not do Morpheus now
and then do a bigger presentation at the
next PlayStation experience you're
talking about Pierce experience yeah
that we did last December
yeah right and that was a great success
you know as far as we are concerned
we have a great great time together lots
of funds and also funds of that time
beyond probably most of them are
converted to kind of funny for better
everything so you know so we are late in
the game of doing this community event
when we learned a lot of the things that
you've been doing at pax or comic-con
but we now know the power of these
events you know to have direct
communication with the you know between
developers and yeah yeah so we have huge
fans of PlayStation experience and we
haven't you know I don't think we have
talked about our ask Adam boys you know
it has to happen if I ask him to boys
anything he just drinks Diet Coke and
talks about John Drake and I don't even
know what's happening anymore he's crazy
man that Adam boys
so our destiny if I've been here but I
have not had was the Cameron destiny one
more time how much time do we have left
reg do you know anyway we're less than
two minutes Wes you she's a quick
question yeah they're not a first-party
studio but they are they work as if they
are a first-party studio Quantic Dream
mmm are we are we right to presume that
they'll show their game in Paris since
they are indeed a studio located in
Paris so four games you a played that we
don't know anything about yet there's so
much there's more than that yeah there
are so many dozens of more games he
knows about what these days making game
takes time yeah so I'm patiently waiting
for the right time to announce or levy
you which will be Paris game with
presumable probably next big show
actually Paris games week happens after
TJ's the other is encrypt because Paris
is October
James Caan is you know August and
usually after e3 was you know August so
game games come we still do the event
and show games for the you know German
but we are not doing any big press
conference we moved it to Paris games
week so the next next actually big show
for us is TGS that's September mid
September I'm still trying to figure out
a way to go this year every time I love
going to Tokyo and you always the last
time I went to Tokyo Shuhei and I went
out to dinner at the restaurant where
they fill in that Kill Bill fight yeah
which was right thanks for inviting yeah
yes we love you so much thank you for
caring about us everybody follow matyoo
OSP and buy playstation products of
course we're unbiased